welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is anne-marie slaughter president and
CEO of New America from 2009 to 2011
professor slaughter served as the
director of policy planning for the
United States Department of State the
first woman to hold that position prior
to her government service professor
slaughter was the Dean of Princeton's
Woodrow Wilson School of Public and
International Affairs she is written or
edited several books including a new
world order the idea that is America
keeping faith with our values in a
dangerous world and unfinished business
women men work family she's also a
frequent contributor to a number of
publications including the Atlantic and
Project Syndicate professor slaughter is
with us today because she's giving the
Harry L Stimson lectures on world
affairs at the Macmillan Center which
Center on her forthcoming book the
chessboard and the web
welcome professor slaughter thank you
it's great to be here let's begin with
an overview of your book tell us about
it
well the chessboard in the web are two
different ways of seeing the world and
for people who are interested in foreign
policy or international relations we
generally think of geopolitics we think
of great powers interacting with each
other competing fighting sometimes
cooperating
that's the chessboard world that is the
world where you think in the Cold War
for instance if the United States did
one thing the Soviet Union would respond
and then the United States would respond
again it's its chessboard strategy that
world's still with us we we have Iran we
have Russia a resurgent we have many
countries where you still have to think
strategically state to state but we also
live in a deeply connected world a world
less of States than of businesses and
citizens and non-governmental groups
universities criminals a web that looks
like the internet if you see it think of
a map of the internet and you have all
these nodes and they're connected to
everybody else that world is a world
just as relevant to foreign policy as
the traditional chessboard so the book
is really about here's what the world
looks like from the chessboard
perspective here's what it looks like
from the web perspective we need both
but and this is the heart of the book we
need a set of tools to fight Isis or to
combat climate change or to think about
how to stimulate entrepreneurship across
in countries that have no really lively
economy or literacy or health we need
tools and those tools are networks and
so the book is really about here's how
to create networks that will help us
achieve goals in the web world and the
foreign policy makers of the future have
to operate both on the chess board and
in the web okay so what gave you the
idea to do the book and I have wanted to
do this book for a long time certainly
since I came out of government and part
of it is really born of my experience in
government working for Secretary Clinton
and one of the things Secretary Clinton
said was diplomacy and development are
equal pillars of our foreign policy
so yes it's important to try to
negotiate a deal with Iran no question
but it's equally important to ensure
that women's rights are protected around
the world that we have strong health
systems so we don't have an Ebola like
crisis to fight terrorism and
trafficking and trafficking in humans
trafficking and drugs trafficking in
arms but what was so striking was again
on that development side we have foreign
assistance programs we give money to
governments and some of them are corrupt
and even if they spend the money on
their people you don't know quite what
they're doing we had no tools for how to
think about those global problems I
couldn't go into Secretary Clinton and
say we should create X and that will
help solve the problem when it stays
to state I can go in and say we should
sanction the state or we should reach an
agreement with this state I didn't have
anything comparable to that on the
development side so this I have long
wanted to write this book and the other
thing I'll say is we live in a world of
networks I live on social media often
and I just felt like none of that was
part of what we study in international
relations and how are you doing the
research for the book backwards I mean
in the sense that I I said one of the
things interesting about this book is I
have collected books in physics books in
economics in sociology in industrial
organization in psychology in technology
and then more recently lots of works on
things like the mesh economy and and
where Silicon Valley's going because
that part of the US economy is all about
networks too so I've collected all these
books and what I've done now is to go
through enough so that I'm giving a set
of lectures I'll now go back with sort
of it's like building the scaffolding of
a house you it takes a while to design
it you have to do a lot of prep to
design it you then once it's up then you
fill it in that's where I so let's get
to the meat of the book give us some
examples of you know some of these 21st
century problems that are affecting
foreign policy well so let me give you a
couple the first one let's think about
Ukraine so Ukraine the Russia invaded
Ukraine 18 months ago took essentially
took over the Crimea and then has been
been destabilizing eastern Ukraine and
this has caused great diplomatic
conflict between Russia and the EU and
the US Russia on one hand the EU and us
in the other now we have lots of chess
board ways of addressing that issue
we've sanctioned Russia we moved troops
into the Baltic States we've supplied
military aid to the Ukrainian government
we've tried to diplomatically isolate
Russia all good and I'm that's the
chessboard
but what what's
here's the Ukrainian people are
desperate for a better life this is the
second revolution they've had they had
one in 2007 they they're on the border
with Poland they can see countries and
governments that are functioning much
better than theirs they're their
governments totally corrupt their
economy stagnant how are we gonna
actually help them achieve the economy
and the government that they want and
that's where the networks come in so I
talked about well first of all let's
build defense networks to make them more
resilient to continued Russian kind of
harassment I mean it's not because
Russia's not marching troops over the
border Russia's infiltrating people and
so I talk about how you can build
defensive networks that make it harder
for Russia actually to destabilize and
then let's think about stabilization and
assistance networks to help not just the
Ukrainian government but there are a
whole class of young digitally savvy
Ukrainians who want startups who want to
build their economy how do we build the
networks that tie them to the right
people in Europe and the United States
and support them so that's one sort of
set of examples another would be let's
say we have a great solution let's say
we know that in one you know one country
this program for teaching kids to read
has worked brilliantly we know that but
it's helped maybe a thousand kids there
are millions of children around the
world need to do that so we need to
figure out how you create a network that
will replicate that program in the same
way if you think of a a that's a classic
example there are there's alcohol AAA
groups right all over the world and they
replicate because somebody wants to
create one and there's a template to do
it or TEDx right these are people love
TED Talks and they can create their own
TEDx conferences so I talked about the
structure of those networks if you
create a template and you create the
right set of incentives you can get a
replication Network so all different
kinds
networks it seems a little odd now
because we haven't done them but they
should be as familiar tools as imposing
sanctions so does the chessboard and the
web ever come together at any point or
do they always remain separate in terms
of solving problems that's a really good
question and and over they certainly
will come together for one thing they'll
conflict if you're trying to build a
network with a country's entrepreneurs
and you need to sanction or you need to
do something that you know isolate them
diplomatically the people you're trying
to network with will respond to the way
you're treating their governments so
there's always going to be trade-offs in
various ways I would say though for most
people this is more like parallel play
one thing the network strategies are
always longer-term
and it's actually very important to put
them in a in place ahead of time so a
good example would be lets say you wanna
you've got a very fragile state there's
been a lot of ethnic tension you want a
network for monitoring violence early on
well you can't put that in place once
there's a crisis in that country that's
too late so the the chessboard
strategies tend to be the short term a
crisis is it what do we do the web
strategies tend to be the longer term
think about how you do this in such a
way that they they have value and that
when the crisis hits they can be
activated so that's why I say I think
you need to I call it seeing in stereo
okay so what about some of the other
problems of the world for instance if we
look at the Syrian refugees for instance
what what what do you offer in terms of
that in terms of solutions web or the
word the chessboard I'm probably a
little both maybe your little both it's
so one for one thing like so Europe is
trying to decide what Europe's policy is
toward refugees that's for European
governments to work out or the United
Nations and the United Nations agencies
trying to help refugees that's the
chessboard I mean it's States coming
together but it's really the chessboard
world on the other end
many more creative solutions that we
have never thought of so one is we think
of refugee camps as places of misery and
squalor and it places people are in and
want to get out of as fast as possible
if you thought about refugee camps in
networks terms you would realize you
have hundreds of thousands of people in
one place a place where you could
provide health and education and
economic training you could make it the
node the central node of networks that
that spread back to the home country and
with the idea that what you're actually
doing is preparing people to go back and
to go back better and we just never
think about a refugee camp that way we
don't think about it as oh my goodness
we've got all these women and children
we could actually and of course we have
education but we don't think of it as an
opportunity to build a better society
for when they go home another idea which
is out of the box there you know the
Greek government has between 500 and
1,500 islands and many people buy those
islands privately you can actually buy
islands online believe it or not I mean
some of us can thank you but there's an
Egyptian billionaire who is buying
islands to build basically not camps for
refugees but cities to build up an
infrastructure where refugees can live
can develop an economy now again if you
think of refugees if there's 60 million
refugees in the world that's that's that
equivalent of you know Hungary and
Belgium in Israel and Norway all put
together so we ought to be thinking of
these people as kind of a nation in
transition and thinking about well how
do you create hubs where you where they
can be in such a way that a they have a
good life but B that's a healthy node
for more positive networks longer term
so what do you hope people take away
from your book I know you're still
working on it so every time you say my
book yes
we're looking at spring go for it yes
we're looking at spring for having it
done it would be another year before
it's actually okay so you know once it
is done what would you like people to
take away what's the idea what I tell
people is I hope that after reading this
book and it will be written in a very
accessible way and it won't be that long
but I hope you'll read the newspaper
differently every morning I hope in what
way well I hope you'll you'll look at
the front page and you'll see us and
Iran at loggerheads or US and Russia or
China and Japan whatever it is and
you'll think oh yes that's the
chessboard
view of this problem now let me read the
article and think about what's the web
view who's connected to whom both to
understand what's going on but also to
anticipate what we could do about it
what tools need to be activated what
your role is in it because the the web
view we're players you know if you're
working for a multinational company if
you're teaching or studying at a global
university if you're part of a civic
group or a church group that's connected
to others that's your part of the world
and so I hope you will see the world
differently you'll read articles
differently you'll ask more intelligent
questions you'll have a better
understanding of how to conduct foreign
policy in a world that is both the
chessboard and the web very good thank
you so much for being here with us today
and sharing some of your work I enjoyed
it for more information about Professor
slaughter and her research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale